have you ever wondered what great people
eat for lunch I'm visiting Santorini
today to explore and eat some good food
and the first thing I noticed is that
Greek people drink more wine than they
do water so of course I had to order a
glass of their traditional wine and some
tomato fritters which were both very
clean and very tasty also the appetizers
here are gorgeous next I ordered a few
different seafood dishes and guys this
was my favorite dish the mussels Seafood
risotto was so creamy and had so much
Umami and I also ordered a seafood plate
and some muscle pasta to try I'm a
sucker for pasta so you already know I
devoured this all and now that I'm all
fueled up I'm off to explode the island
bye